let's talk about the nine best ketogenic
diet ingredients all right now this is
based on two things one is low carb and
nutrient-dense the number one would be
shellfish and I'm talking about clams
oysters mussels absolutely amazing for
their trace minerals zinc selenium
iodine chromium and it has DHA what is
DHA that's a real key on mega 3 fatty
acid so hands down shellfish has the
best trace minerals and healthy fats
number 2 salmon and I'm talking about
Wow caught out of all the fish wild
caught salmon has one of the highest
amounts of omega-3 fatty acids and the
two types that I'm talking about our DHA
and EPA great for the retina of the eye
your brain and the heart and also
high-quality protein as well number
three leafy greens like salads why
because it has the minerals potassium
magnesium and loaded with vitamin C and
these are very easy to digest so I would
consume these raw all right number four
sardines sardines are loaded with the
DHA and EPA those are the omega-3 fatty
acids plus it's really good protein
number five eggs and I'm talking about
organic pasture-raised eggs have pretty
much every single vitamin except they
don't have a lot of vitamin C but other
than that they have pretty much
everything else I consume a lot of eggs
and they're very very healthy
they will not increase your cholesterol
if you've heard that eggs will worsen
your cholesterol watch that link down
below because I go through it in depth
and you can actually get the true data
on that but eggs are really really
healthy number six cruciferous
vegetables now with most cruciferous
especially brussel sprouts
and other cruciferous vegetables I
recommend that you steam them because
that will even enhance the final
nutrients
in cruciferous vegetables the big
benefit of cruciferous go beyond just
their vitamins and minerals because
they're loaded with phytonutrients and
phytonutrients are the extra health
factors that can decrease the
complications from diabetes from
Alzheimer's it can minimize the damage
that some of these diseases are creating
and also protect you against cancer
alright number seven
avocados low carb healthy fats they're
extremely healthy but some people can
get bloated if they do too many so I'm
just making a special note of that but
overall they're very very healthy and
number eight olives and olive oil extra
virgin and organic really good on a
ketogenic diet and number nine grass-fed
grass-finished very important because
they will sometimes finish the cattle
off with grains which could be GMO to
fatten them up for a period of even like
ten months so that's not good
you wanted a hundred percent certified
grass-fed grass-finished and I recommend
not necessarily having a lean piece of
steak but have a fatty of burger because
that extra fat can even lower the effect
on insulin and it's easier to digest and
that also includes grass-fed
grass-finished organic hot dogs as well
now on the flip side there are a lot of
foods that we that people eat that are
nothing remotely connected to the
ketogenic diet there are worse than
names like sugar and grains but I'm
going to talk about some of the foods
that people doing keto consume in a
regular basis as in dirty keto and I
want to talk about that first of all
some people consider corn one of the
vegetables and they consume corn on the
ketogenic diet and they will consume
maybe a little bit well the problem is
that most corn like 95% is GMO and this
is the big problem in addition to the
corn being highly glycemic so you don't
want to consume corn despite it being a
vegetable now yogurt has
a lot of sugar but some people consume
the Greek yogurt but you need to look at
the label because you're gonna be
surprised how much sugar is in Greek
yogurt now if you're having a small
amount here and there and you're
counting those carbs it might be okay
but make sure it's organic and grass-fed
but overall it's still not a really good
ingredient all right next one
commercial chicken unfortunately the
chicken is badly processed factory
farmed fed grains overall not the ideal
protein you want to do on a healthy keto
plan alright next one is processed meat
I'm talking about my cold cuts and
things like that even though that would
be considered Quito
you have nitrates you have a lot of
added sugar sometimes they add
monosodium glutamate and definitely it's
not grass-fed so I'm not gonna recommend
this right here either
now cheese I consume some chase on a
regular basis so it really is the type
of cheese
processed cheese or not from cows that
are grass-fed I don't recommend that
cheese so if you're gonna do cheese I
would definitely do grass-fed or organic
or don't consume it at all but there's a
lot of people that are sensitive to
certain things and cheese cheese is
originally from milk and there are a lot
of hormonal factors going on there that
can influence someone with a prostate
issue also it can influence women who
have problems with fibroids and cysts in
the breasts or the ovaries so if there's
anything going on with estrogen
dominance I don't recommend it and if
you're going to consume it I don't
recommend consuming a lot of it a little
bit here and there
alright spinach if the problem with
spinach is it's loaded with oxalates
oxalates can actually cause kidney
stones you might be okay if you're not a
stone former you've never had a kitty
stone and you're not having a problem
and you consumed spinach you may be okay
but what's interesting is if you consume
some cheese you know high-quality cheese
with the spinach this calcium will bind
with the oxalates in your digestive
system
it won't get absorbed into the blood
into the kidney so the calcium of the
cheese can protect you against the
stones FYI but I just wouldn't recommend
a lot of spinach I would consume other
vegetables
all right nuts you can definitely overdo
it on the nuts but almonds have the
highest amount of oxalates and if you
have a tendency to get kidney stones not
a good idea some people that are
arthritic should stay away from these as
well because you'd be surprised how many
people that have arthritis really have
just too many foods high in oxalates
which can irritate the joints so if
you're going to consume nuts or nut
butters or even seeds probably have just
a small amount it's really easy to do
too many nuts and that can irritate the
gall bladder and the liver and the
digestive tract and vegetables
it sounds really healthy vegetable oils
when in fact this is really grain oils
they're usually GMO highly inflammatory
but their keto friendly because they're
low carb and higher fat so there you
have it this is the good list and this
is the bad alright thanks for watching
and if you haven't already subscribed
click the red button below and that
little bell icon so you can be notified
of all the new videos that I'm gonna be
releasing and I have some very cool and
interesting videos coming up in the next
coming weeks plus in addition to that
you'll be notified of the live Q&A
sessions that I'm going to be doing
throughout the week and you don't want
to miss those as well so stay tuned for
more great content